notre invité politique ce matin c'est
guillaume larrivé bonjour bien arrivé
bon jour pour nous d'être avec nous
députés les républicains de l'yonne
président de la france demain en 10
secondes c'est quoi la france demain la
france demain c'est un mouvement
national et libérale au sein des
républicains vous savez que j'avais
porté une candidature à la présidence
des républicains il ya un an et demi et
c'est un un courant mais c'est un
mouvement d'idées et voilà comme ça
s'est précisé et c'est une interview
comme tous les jours et en partenariat
avec la presse quotidienne régionale et
bonjour fabrice veysseyre redon et
bonjour merci beaucoup d'interviews
fabrice du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france dont vos
journaux régionaux guillaume larrivé on
commence bien sûr par cet entretien
publié ce matin par emmanuel macron dans
la presse quotidienne régionale il a
donc détaillé son plan de déconfinement
calendrier progressif en quatre étapes
qui vont de lundi prochain au 30 juin
pas de déconfinement par territoire mais
un déconfinement national avec toutefois
des freins d'urgence
est ce que vous dites qu'il a trouvé le
bon calendrier la bonne méthode ça mais
moi je souhaite évidemment le succès de
la france et j'espère de tout mon coeur
est avec ardeur que ce plan de
réouverture sera un succès pour notre
pays c'est un plan très volontariste
est-ce qu'il est réaliste ou est ce
qu'il est au contraire trop optimistes
au fond c'est la question qu'on doit se
poser
je reste inquiet lorsque je regarde
comme vous les chiffres chaque jour
c'est l'équivalent d'un airbus a320 qui
s'écrase en france à cause du coc vide
on a environ 3 300 morts par jour on
encore alors on se parle
cinq mille huit cents lits de
réanimation ou de soins intensifs qui
sont occupées par des malades qu'ovide
on a on le sait la menace d'un certain
nombre de variantes ont saison
et s'ils vont constituer une menace très
grave
enfin on peut le craindre bref il ya
encore beaucoup de clignotants rouges
qui sont hélas ouvert mais je voudrais
ce matin la proposition craignant
l'arrêt je voudrais ce matin à faire une
proposition
il me semble que pour que ce plan de
réouverture réussisse il faut en
parallèle qu'on est vraiment un plan
100% vaccination est donc très
concrètement ce que je souhaite c'est
qu'on ait dès le 1er mai c'est à dire
dès maintenant une ouverture de la
vaccination à tous les français de plus
de 50 ans et qu'on est le 1er juin une
ouverture de la vaccination à tous les
français de plus de 40 ans voilà ce que
je souhaite
il me semble que on doit absolument
amplifier le volume le rythme de la
vaccination pour avoir un plan de
couverture à 100% le plus rapidement
possible de l'ensemble de la population
adulte
pourquoi je dis plus de 50 ans une fois
parce qu'à cette amère de droite qui
disent il faut ouvrir la vaccination à
tous sans critère d'âge j'ai essayé de
regard des rencontres tenues aussi des
stocks de vaccination il faut être
réaliste jeudi dès 50 ans dès le 1er mai
je crois que le gouvernement dit le 15
mai pour les plus de 50 ans
je pense que voilà faisons le maintenant
on voit bien qu'il ya des doses hélas
qui sont gâchées on le sait tous dans
nos territoires nous faisons plus de 50
ans dès maintenant et plus de 40 ans
dans un mois le 1er juin plus de 40 ans
pourquoi parce que c'est l'âge médian
l'âge médian d'après l'insee c'est 40,8
ou 41 ans
voilà je pense qu'il faut y aller faut y
aller à fond est-ce qu'en plus
oriane mancini on est capable comme
certains pays d'aller vers un plan
d'éradication du coc vide 0 qu'ovide je
l'espère mais je veux pas n'est ce pas
promettre de la poudre de perlimpinpin
j'observe c'est le choix jolie soeur qui
est long mais avait par emmanuel match
conserve quand même il ya quelques
techniques qu'on utilise semble-t-il pas
ou pas assez en france je pense à
l'identification des supers
contaminateur savais qu'avec un système
d'anticipation des analyses des eaux
usées il ya certains pays qui sont
capables
d'identifier le super contaminateur et
d'aller l'isoler très vite je crois qu
on le fait passer j'aimerais qu'on soit
capable aussi d'équiper nos écoles de
purificateur d'art de systèmes de
désinfection puisse enfin je pense qu'on
a encore des marges de progression
technique
ce que je voudrais dire pour conclure
pour pas être trop long là dessus c'est
que je ne doute je ne doute pas de la
bonne volonté des uns des autres
voilà mon propos est signé c'est un
autre choix politique a été fait par
emmanuel lacroix emmanuel macron il
redit ce matin dans la presse kolo et
régionales il faut apprendre à vivre
avec lui mais son choix était là dans la
stratégie zéro kobe bryant chine il
vivre avec le co vide
ça veut dire aussi accepter de mourir
parfois à cause du coc vide bien donc je
n'aime pas trop cette formule vivre avec
un danger mortel
je pense qu'il faut une approche
réaliste
j'espère que ce plan de couverture sera
un succès il me semble que la condition
du succès c'est d'avoir un vrai plan
100% vaccination et moi je propose un
chemin qui n'est pas le chemin de
gouvernement avec l'ouverture à tous les
plus de 50 ans dès maintenant dès le 1er
mai et l'ouverture aux plus de 40 ans
dans un mois
dès le 1er juin c'est ce que je voulais
dire ce matin pas sanitaire a écrit
brice pas d'ouverture à la vaccination à
tous tout de suite c'est en tout cas ce
qui ressort d'un dépôt des propositions
faites présentation faite par le
président de la république
derrière se pose la question du passé ni
terre en france notamment pour toute la
partie culture à partir du mois de juin
vous positionnez comment vous soit pas
sanitaires il ya deux sujets yens une
question de principe et une question
technique sur la question technique il
faut qu'on regarde très précisément dans
la loi
j'ai commencé un peu regardé le projet
de loi dont on été saisis mercredi bon
ça c'est une question de commissions une
question technique pour bien voir sur le
principe
si on a véritablement progresser sur la
vaccination
c'est logique d'avoir ce qu'on appelle
cette espèce de passeports sanitaires
pour accéder à un certain nombre de
lieux il le conçoit en produisant ce ne
soit en produisant soit en produisant la
vaccination soit en produisant la preuve
qu' on a eu le coz id mais qu'on est
encore couvert par avoir été soit est
extrêmement récent pcr négatif on voit
bien que ces trois éléments qui sont
d'ailleurs skis
dans le projet de loi de mercredi qui
sont plutôt conformes à ce que la
commission européenne est par ailleurs
le certificat vert enfin bon bref je
pète trop trop technique sur le principe
c'est logique mais ça ne peut aller ça
ne peut aller que si ce plan de 100 %
vaccination devient une réalité au delà
du au delà du slogan mais c'est logique
si on veut retrouver notre liberté
d'aller et venir
il faut évidemment qu'on ait cette donc
poutine en vaccinant masse et en
délivrant pas sanitaires à ceux qui le
sont ça me paraît le plus raisonnable
dans le passé le chef de l'état a dit
que le parlement sera saisi sur cette
question précise du passé ni et bien je
regarderai le texte vous savez je n'ai
pas pour habitude parlementaire
maintenant depuis 9 ans de dire c'est ce
que je vais voter avant d'avoir lu
précisément ce qu'on propose de voter
autre sujet qui concerne peut-être le
parlement emmanuel macron qui dit qui
aura des concertations la semaine
prochaine avec les parlementaires avec
les élus locaux avec les partenaires
sociaux et que jean castex détaillera
dans la semaine du 10 mai son plan de
déconfinement de manière plus précise
est ce que vous demandez un vote au
parlement sur ce plan je sais pas s'il
faut nécessairement un vote sur un plan
global
ce que je pense quand même et je le dis
si au sénat c'est que c'est pas du tout
à propos corporatiste mais je trouve
qu'on manque je parle pour l'assemblée
nationale en tout cas d'un lieu où il
puisse y avoir à nouveau des auditions
précise interrogations précise le petit
théâtre de la séance de 15 heures le
mardi que les questions d'actualité
pardon de le dire mais c'est pas ça qui
fait avancer le schmilblick en général
en revanche un vrai travail de mission
d'information comme ç'avait été le cas
ces derniers mois avec notamment damien
abad eric ciotti le président richard
ferrand voilà je trouve que ça manque
et ça serait les français moi j'aimerais
que à l'assemblée on puisse auditionner
tel ou tel responsable pour l'interroger
par exemple sur l'état précis
aujourd'hui des clusters ou pas de
variants indien voilà j'ai vu que dans
un département du sud-ouest et un cac
identifiés et des suspicions ailleurs
voilà j'aimerais qu'on puisse
s'interroger en réalité aujourd'hui
parlementaire que je suis pour être
informé
les journaux attentivement ses dires des
notes
j'ai des contacts aussi et territoriaux
avec l'agent soins de santé les
préfectures mais je trouve que dans
notre fonction de contrôle et de et de
propositions plutôt que de nous faire
des grands mais c'est un vote global 56
1 de la constitution une fois tous les
deux mois
on devrait avoir de manière responsable
raisonnable un vrai travail de mission
d'évaluation
voilà un mot juste sur l'économie après
on va parler terrorisme avec fabrice
mais un mot on en parle moins mais il a
quand même été question d'économie dans
cet entretien du chef de l'état à la
presse quotidienne régionale
il assume le quoi qu'il en coûte c'est
ce qui dit je l'assumé totalement il dit
durant la crise de 2008 la france a une
récession deux fois moins forte qu'en
allemagne mais elle a décrit cette fois
plus d'emplois là nous n'ont détruit non
plus car on à protéger les emplois
existants
c'est quand même un sévère tacle à la
droite et à nicolas sarkozy et à sa
gestion de la crise de 2008 qu'est ce
que vous dites bon je pense que le
prénom la république a tort de faire ce
petit commentaire rétrospectif un petit
peu or deux hors de propos je rappelle
d'ailleurs que cette époque là jean
castex était à l'elysée je l'étais aussi
on était collègues j'étais le conseiller
juridique jean castex était le
conseiller social enfin bon on va pas
non plus faire l'histoire de ce qui
s'est passé il ya 13 ans mon sujet
aujourd'hui au plan économique je pense
qu'on a eu raison
on a eu raison et je n'y font parce que
je les beautés de voter un plan de
relance massive pour injecter des
liquidités protéger certains nombre
d'emplois faire de l'activité partielle
avoir un fond de solidarité etc etc
mais là où le gouvernement a eu tort et
la cour des comptes l'a démontré il ya
quelques semaines c'est que les dépenses
orco vides ont continué à augmenter
beaucoup et ça va il n'y a pas de
miracle
un jour il faudra que l'hélicoptère
monétaire atterrissent un mois je pense
qu'on a devant nous un mur fameux mire
de la dette
on a peut-être aussi un autre mur qui
celui de l'inflation
donc je pense que autant il faut
injecter des liquidités dans la relance
post coded autant il faut aussi ne pas
abandonner l'objectif de vraie maîtrise
des dépenses publiques
or que vides les arbres ne grimpent pas
au ciel et on ne pourra pas
éternellement avoir une dette publique
et des dépenses publiques qui explose
son sujet puisque vous évoquez votre
passé
à l'elysée notamment on a une impression
jusqu'à présent il y avait une bonne
entente entre nicolas sarkozy emmanuel
macron assez peu de tirs de balles entre
eux c'est la fin de la lune de miel
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est ce qui
se passe à ce stade de la vie politique
non je veux pas trop entrer dans ce
genre de commentaire nicolas sarkozy et
l'ancien président de la république il
est normal qu'ils échangent de manière
républicaine responsable raisonnable
avec l'actuel président de la république
il est normal que nicolas sarkozy ne
soit pas dans le débat politique
quotidien il est encore plus
satisfaisant qu'il n'entre pas dans des
polémiques médiocres voilà il est aussi
vous savez une personnalité de bons
conseils
pour le président de la république comme
pour ceux qui au sein des républicains
aspire à retrouver un jour le chemin des
responsabilités allez on va parler de
l'autre actualité du jour et c'est cet
hommage national rendu ce matin à la
police hier assassiné par un terroriste
et on va parler de ces questions de
terrorisme fabrice et oui une loi anti
terroriste est présenté par le
gouvernement vous pourriez la voter
cette loi
oui j'espère que je serai capable de
trouver avec le ministre de l'intérieur
un un terrain d'entente
ce que je veux dire pour nous les
auditeurs et les téléspectateurs faut
être extrêmement sérieux et assez
modeste sur ces questions une loi ne
règle pas tout on a déjà beaucoup
d'instruments dans le code pénal dans le
code de la sécurité un cari et beaucoup
de bien sûr mais on a besoin d'ajuster
en fonction de l'évolution technologique
en fonction de la menace
le texte qui a été présenté mercredi il
est le résultat de réflexions assez
longue
j'avais avec d'autres présenté au mois
de juin 2020 un rapport d'évaluation de
la loi de 2015 sur le renseignement
on a par exemple le sujet de la
technique de l'algorithme vous et moi on
va sur facebook sur google sur d'autres
sites d'achats en ligne et on est
suspecté par des algorithmes commerciaux
je pense qu'il est utile que la dgsi la
direction générale de la sécurité
intérieure dispose d'un algorithme
permettant non pas d'organiser une
surveillance de masse des honnêtes
citoyens mais de détecter des connexions
qui sont là disent d'un comportement
djihadistes bon tout ça est hyper
encadré on a une commission nationale de
contrôle des techniques de renseignement
d'un contrôle juridictionnel par le
conseil d'état et on a je veux le dire à
votre antenne une nouvelle fois des
hommes et des femmes fonctionnaires ou
contractuels qui travaillent dans nos
services de renseignements dans nos
services d'espionnage dans nos services
de contre espionnage qui sont des hommes
et des femmes de grande qualité
technique mais aussi de grandes qualités
humaines ce sont des patriotes
ce sont des soldats en réalité qui
défendent notre pays et je voudrais pas
que dans ces débats sur la loi relative
aux renseignements on entretienne un
petit climat de suspicion à l'endroit de
ses agents de l'état de droit
l'état de droit doit être fort il doit
être un outil y est juridiquement et
technologiquement pour protéger les
français vous êtes d'accord avec le
gouvernement sur ce sujet l'autre volet
de cette loi un parmi d'autres c'est le
suivi des terroristes c'est une centaine
de terroristes qui sont libérés dans les
prochains mois vous vous critiquiez il
ya quelques mois la passivité du
gouvernement sur ce sujet c'était dans
une tribune au figaro là le texte
renforce les moyens de suivi de ces
terroristes est ce que
vous dites c'est bon on fait ce qu'il
faut non là j'ai un vrai des accords
techniques avec les équipes
gouvernementales sur la question des
sortants de prison c'est un sujet que
j'essaie de regarder de près depuis 2014
pas par pas mal de rapports
parlementaires pas mal de visites en
prison et pas mal de travaux juridiques
moi je pense que il faut qu'on soit
hyper réaliste là dessus vous avez des
djihadistes qui sont de dangerosité
différentes mais certains sont de
véritables bêtes fauves extrêmement
dangereuses qui sont en train de sortir
de prison parce que c'est des individus
qui avaient rejoint les filières irako
syrienne dans les années 2012 2013 ils
ont été condamnés à sept huit ans de
prison ils sont donc libérable en 2020
2021 2022
c'est ça le sujet ce stock si j'ose dire
de djihadistes qui va être libéré de
prison
on en fait quoi aujourd'hui on les
pistes par des outils de renseignement
interceptions de sécurité voir banni
c'est ok ça il faut évidemment continuer
à voir ses outils et les musclés il ya
par ailleurs quelques petites mesures
qu'on appelle les mika ce sont des
mesures administratives que le
gouvernement veut un petit peu améliorée
mais pour moi c'est presque une cautère
sur une jambe de bois si vous voulez ou
une rustine sur le le pneu presque
creuser d'agde un vélo si vous voulez je
pense que pour certains de ces
djihadistes les plus dangereux il faut
qu'on assume de définir dans nos textes
juridiques des mesures d' enfermement
c'est la rétention judiciaire et c'est
pour ça que j'aimerais qu'on crée un
tribunal de sécurité nationale nouvel
outil juridictionnelle qui déciderait
des mesures de rétention judiciaire
poste peine de prison
j'espère ne pas être technique mais il
c'est une vraie différence
d'appréciation cloud 20 morts j'en ai
déjà parlé avec le miso l'intérieur avec
le premier ministre
voilà je pense qu'ils ont pas envie de
faire ce pas qui est juridiquement assez
audacieux jeanjean j'en conviens ça
suppose d'avoir un débat assez rugueuse
avec le conseil constitutionnel actuel
sans doute mais il faut aussi qu'on
assume nos responsabilités je suis moi
favorable à ce que l'état de droit soit
fort pour protéger les français et c'est
un slogan ça doit se traduire par des
mesures opérationnelles sont des mesures
réalistes
je suis pas du tout ce qu'ils vous
disent il ya qu'à tous les condamnés à
perpétuité il ya qu à tous est expulsé
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
quand on connaît de l'intérieur le
ministère de l'intérieur si j'ose dire
on sait que c'est compliqué il faut pas
dire n'importe quoi mais il faut pas non
plus se résoudre à une espèce de statu
quo qui serait en réalité une forme de
démission
allez on va passer à un autre qualité
c'est cette tribune des militaires qui
continuent de faire polémique
oui on vous a entendu vous exprimer sur
le sujet ces militaires qui appelle
emmanuel macron à agir face au
délitement à cette menace
vous avez notamment dénoncé une
récupération de la part de marine le pen
sur ce sur ce sujet vous pensez que ces
militaires doivent être sanctionnés
monpoint s'est distingué un peu la forme
et le fond sur le fond que des citoyens
disent qu'il ya des tensions dans le
pays tous à bord mettons la tribune
aurait été apporte pas grand chose quand
on la lit c'est un peu des généralistes
est d'accord sur le fond passe par
exemple bruno retailleau rachida native
il partage le constat qui est dans la
tribune missions critiques sur la puce
gg à créhange écrit en mars 2013 et à
ton bien longtemps une tribune dans
valeurs actuelles qui ça ne vous disait
demain pour interrogation la guerre
civile non pas pour le souhaitez mais
pour redouter ce scénario apocalyptique
donc j'en fais aussi d'accord je pars
dont je joue laissez-moi libre de ne pas
forcément adhérer à toutes les formules
à tous les mômes enfin l'état d'esprit
général selon lequel le pays dans une
situation de grande tension
oui bien sûr est ce que ce genre de
tribune ajoute à la tension
je le crains et donc je pense cette
tribu n'était pas opportune bien elle
est d'autant moins opportune qu'elle
vient d'un certain nombre de militaires
soit d'actifs soit en deuxième section
qui sont tenus un devoir de deux de
réserve
je le dis comme député comme citoyens et
même comme fils de colonel en retraite
bon je suis plutôt un fana mili donc
j'ai pas du tout soupçonnable d'être
hostiles à ce que les armées françaises
peuvent faire bien au contraire c'est
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
les armes et beaucoup de respect pour
les soldats les sous-officiers les
officiers et officiers généraux de
l'armée française c'est précisément
parce que j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
les armes et que je n'accepte pas
qu'elles soient instrumentalisées dans
un petit combat partisan et mon point
vous l'avez noté
je trouve tout à fait inacceptable que
madame le pen comme chef de parti et cru
pouvoir lancer un appel aux généraux
j'ai lu sa lettre
messieurs les officiers généraux
rejoignez moi dans le combat politique
qu'est ce que c'est que ces histoires
lorsqu'on prétend lorsqu'on prétend être
candidat à cette responsabilité suprême
qui est celle de diriger les armées et
de diriger l'état on ne se comporte pas
comme ça on n'appelle pas les armes et à
rejoindre un combat politique
les armées de la nation ce sont les
armées de l'ensemble des français
elles doivent obéissance aux
institutions démocratiquement choisi par
le suffrage universel
elles n'ont pas être instrumentalisée
dans un petit combat politicien
madame le pen a commis une faute contre
l'état et je crois d'ailleurs qu'elle a
perdu aussi une occasion de se taire
on va parler des régionales en bourgogne
franche comté et oui en bourgogne
franche comté bas des choses sur un
petit peu tendu en ce moment avec le
rapprochement entre la liste que vous
soutenez celle de gilles platret
candidats et républicain de la droite et
du centre a donc des candidats venant de
debout la france le parti de nicolas
dupont aignan vous pensez que c'est une
c'est une opportunité ces régionales de
retravailler avec nicolas dupont aignan
je suis très content qu on entre enfin
dans le débat régional là je parle comme
député bourguignon comme député de
l'yonne je suis de ceux dé l'été dernier
qui ont fait le choix de pousser gilles
platret à être notre candidat à titre
personnel dire je ne suis candidat à
rien d'autre qu'à exercer mon mandat de
député je suis candidat ni aux
régionales de départementale c'est un
choix que j'ai fait dans ma tête démare
élection de député en 2017 fin de la
parenthèse je vous réponds la situation
de la bourgogne franche comté elle est
très simple les républicains au tour de
gilles platret nous sommes la force
centrale de la politique en bourgogne
franche comté
on a d'un côté une espèce de mauvais
souple rose rouge verte autour de la
présidente sortante qui a tiré la région
vers le bas en termes de résultats en
termes de désindustrialisation en termes
d'insécurité en termes d'abandon un
certain nombre de territoires donc une
espèce de mauvaise soupe rose rouge
verte ps avec en réalité des vélleités
d'alliance avec
islamo gauchiste de la france insoumise
large à droite
attendez laissez moi faire le
résonnement si vous permettez donc cette
mauvaise soupe rose rouge verte
moi j'en veux plus et j'ai envie qu'on
libère la région bourgogne franche comté
de cette espèce de broue qui tire la
région vers le bas et puis de l'autre
côté on a une liste front national
extrémistes qui ressemble à rien et que
naturellement on ne veut surtout pas
voir accéder à la présidence de la
région donc on se base sur ces deux
fronts là et nous sommes nous la force
centrale
la force de la droite républicaine et du
centre droit dans mon département de
l'yonne je me réjouis par exemple on est
en train de composer tout cela avec
gilles platret on va avoir une belle
liste de territoires avec naturellement
des républicains jean pierre cros a
journey 1 200 têtes de liste et une
autre tête de liste céline barrage en
mer dos avant qu'un binôme tête de liste
on va voir des udi avec le soutien de la
sénatrice dominique j'ai rien et du
député andré villiers qui sont au pays
et puis on aura aussi l'arrivée d'autres
d'autres personnes venant de la droite
parfois un peu plus souffrir en ont fait
une vraie alliance comment on se bat
contre le front national le
rassemblement national avec sur sa liste
des membres du parti debout la france le
parti de nicolas dupont aignan dont
marine le pen voulait faire son premier
ministre et bien ça c'était en 2017 mais
quand vous regardez de près la situation
dans ma région de bourgogne franche
comté vous a vu sa moralité au sein de
debout la france une scission mais à
seulement deux personnes qui sont
parties vers le rassemblement national
7,6 à son parti et puis vous en avez
d'autres qui sont en fait des militants
qui sont je dirais sur une ligne pasqua
seguin version 2021 et au nom de quoi on
les écarterait de la volonté d'en finir
avec cette alliance rose rouge verte
au nom de quoi qu'il ait pensé à aucune
raison de cela il est temps pour vous de
retravailler avec nicolas dupont aignan
je vous ai répondu pour la bourgogne
franche comté en bourgogne franche comté
je suis complètement convaincu que cette
force centrale autour de notre candidat
à la présidence de région gilles platret
force d'union de rassemblement de la
droite républicaine jusqu'au centre
droit tout ça me paraît être la formule
gagnante le le centre va rester avec
vous parce que françois sauvadet
il est très critique sur cette alliance
s'est dit qu'il veut pas donner il a eu
quelques il est énorme et donc je ne
suis pas sûr d une heure oui c'est des
humeurs et j'observe que françois
sauvadet a à trois reprises en 2004 en
2010 et en 2015 a échoué à battre
l'alliance des socialistes des
communistes et des écologistes en
bourgogne je ne suis pas absolument
convaincu qu'il soit aujourd'hui comment
dire le mieux en situation de nous
donner des leçons je pense qu'il faut
qu'ils acceptent qu'une génération
nouvelle a décidé de conquérir la
bourgogne franche comté là où
malheureusement il n'avait pas été en
situation de nous conduire à la victoire
et ce sera le mot de la fin mai si vous
n'arrivez merci beaucoup d'avoir est de
notre avis et on regarde la une de l'est
républicain déconfinement 4 temps et
d'ailleurs fabrice dans tous les
journaux du concret bras bien sûr
l'entretien d' emmanuel macron à la
presse quotidienne régionale merci
beaucoup monsieur
[Musique]